hey what's going on my name's samuel and
in this video i want to talk to you
about how to be a very successful
property deal saucer so if you enjoy my
youtube channel if you like my content
do me a favor smash the like button
below and also make sure you are
subscribed to the channel so i've just
been running a training program today at
my house i've had a bunch of students
here and you know what not only have i
personally packaged and sold over 200
deals
but i've also helped many many other
people do the same you know you see a
lot of people that are making uh
full-time salaries from literally just
packaging and selling a deal a month so
in this video i'm going to tell you uh
firstly what deal packaging is but also
how to sell deals because there's a big
missing ingredient that most people have
no idea how to do and in this video i'm
going to share what the missing
ingredient is and i'm going to not only
share what it is but i'm also going to
fill in the gaps and give you the skills
that you can actually do it again if
this sounds good hit the like button um
so firstly what is deal selling deal
selling is when you package a deal a
property investment
and you sell it to an investor and you
take a commission fee typically around
about two to five thousand pounds now
think about it if you're just doing that
once a month what's that called that's
called a full-time salary that means
that you're making a full-time salary by
literally just packaging and selling one
deal a month i mean what a great way to
make money and what are you gonna do
with the best deals you're gonna keep
them of course for yourself so you're
effectively getting paid to find the
best deals
the thing that stops people being able
to package and sell deals is they don't
know
that to package and sell deals the
investor comes first
so i see people all the time they go
ahead and they find a deal
oh my gosh i just found a really good
below market value property
oh my goodness i just found a hmo
and then they're trying to flog this
deal
that maybe nobody wants
and then the estate agent is like saying
what's going on and it's just terrible
so if you want to be a property deal
sourcer you want to package and sell
deals the first thing that you need is
you need an investor that you can work
with that will pay you to actually find
the deal
so how do you find the investor
well you just hang out in places that
investors go
today around my house
we've had about 20 people
you know i've had some of my mentors
some on my team some of my students and
you know what they are they're all
they're all investors they're all buying
and investing in properties so
if you're property networking events if
you head down to property networking
events guess what there is people
there's people everywhere they're doing
what they're investing in property how
many do you need to do business with
one
just one so what you want to do
get where investors are
ask them what do you do for a living and
guess what they're probably going to say
they're probably going to say i'm a
property investor
of course because we're a property
investment networking event
and then you're going to ask them
what is it that you're looking for
simple what is it that you're looking
for this is the most successful people
in business do this two things number
one they ask people what they want
number two they then give them what they
want
ask people what they want and then give
them what they want so if with property
investment if you're wanting to package
and sell deals ask investors
what kind of properties are you looking
for what are you hoping to invest in and
then when they tell you what they're
looking for say that's great well i'm
actually a deal sourcer
and i'm looking to package and sell
deals if i can find you something like
that
do you want me to send you over an email
join me to send you an email with the
details
and if they say yes then you go out and
you search what that person is looking
for that's how you do deal sourcing
another thing is
you should charge that person a fee okay
this is really interesting now charging
a fee
up front
we call this bespoke deal sourcing so
how does this work man this is important
so
let's say someone says i'm looking for
development opportunities i'm looking
for below market value hmo brr flips or
whatever it is i'm looking for lease
options i'm looking for service
departments in leeds city center
whatever it is they're looking for
you're gonna say okay cool
you're gonna go out put some feelers out
and if you think if you're feeling
pretty confident that you can find
something good for them give them a
little bit of an idea what you're
looking at and they say look
i'm gonna go out and i'm gonna go to
town and i'm gonna find you what you
want my fee is 3 000 pounds
however
what i'm going to suggest is that you
give me 1 000 pounds up front
as a bespoke sourcing fee
that is fully refundable
if i don't find something within six
weeks
that you're perfectly happy with i'm
gonna refund you that one thousand
pounds
then they pay the one thousand pounds
you have a little contract between the
two here then guess what bank you're
gonna go to town looking for what they
want
and you're going to find something of
course you're going to find something
meanwhile you're getting more investors
adding more investors to your list
and then you're going to find something
and then go hey i've got what you want
what do you think it looks great good
could have my other 2 grand place
and then that way you're not running out
like a headless chicken trying to find
property deals when you ain't got anyone
that wants the deals so
i hope that's been helpful that's deal
selling 101 if you want to see more
videos just like this i'm gonna be
putting out so much content on youtube
honestly so much i've made millions of
pounds in property and i really enjoy
seeing other people win i've helped
hundreds of people become completely
financially free and property and a lot
of them have all started here on this
youtube channel so you want to see more
content like this let me know in the
comments
hit the like button to let me know you
enjoy this kind of content and i'll see
you guys real soon peace out